und für uns hat das ganze mein kollege
erhard scherfer verfolgt er hat wie
überzeugend ist der finanzminister denn
im u-ausschuss aufgetreten na ja das
wird recht unterschiedlich bewertet er
selber wird sehr zufrieden sein die spd
auch bei der union und bei großen teilen
der opposition sieht das ganz anders aus
tatsache ist dass der regel relativ
ruhig aufgetreten ist sehr gut
vorbereitet war gelegentlich erheitert
von den fragen und dass er unter anderem
der opfer wiesen hat dass er ja erst
seit 20 18 unter im märz
bundesfinanzminister ist also für die
meisten der vorgänge oder sich die
meisten der vorgänge rund um wirecard
gar nicht in seiner amtszeit abgespielt
haben er hat wir haben sie im beitrag
eben auch schon gesehen darauf verwiesen
dass sowohl das finanzministerium als
auch die finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht
richtig gehandelt habe aufgrund der
datenlage damals aufgrund des wissens zu
damals und wer hat die gelegenheit
genutzt immer mal wieder zu promoten was
er bereits im vergangenen juni vorgelegt
hat nämlich änderungen bei der
finanzdienst aufsicht also ein
entsprechendes gesetz das im moment noch
im gesetzgebungsverfahren ist also hat
da immer wieder darauf verwiesen und hat
vor diesem hintergrund dann auch
eingeräumt dass damals natürlich mit dem
wissen von heute tatsächlich fehler
passiert sind unterm strich weil man
nach sieben stunden anhörung hier des
bundesfinanzministers pausen inklusive
und eine beratungssitzung inklusive
inklusive allerdings nicht wirklich viel
schlauer und das einzige was wir dann
behalten haben aus all dieser zeit ist
dass der minister ein
genossenschaftsanteil an der touch
besitzt und dass er gelegentlich mails
schreibt vom privaten account durchaus
auch an staatssekretäre und genau daran
hat sich dann allerdings die kritik
entzündet der mann hatte ihm vorgehalten
nicht umfassend zur aufklärung
beizutragen wir hören einige o-töne von
den abgeordneten dieses
untersuchungsausschuss im anschluss an
die befragung des weiteren besorgt mich
an der stelle schon ich habe das gestern
schon mal so flapsig formuliert keiner
hat fehler gemacht und aus diesem wollen
wir lernen das so recht kein ministerium
nach wie vor kein hoher beamter kein
minister irgendwo fehler im eigenen
ablauf im ministerium so richtig
einräumt
letztlich ist es zu diesem riesengroßen
finanzskandal gekommen weil viele ihren
job nicht richtig nicht mit dem biss
oder mit der auslegungssache
entsprechend geleistet haben und hier
nochmals stelle ich ganz klar für mich
fest diese sogenannte leerverkauf
verordnung und auch diese dieses
leerverkaufsverbot was dann im februar
am 18 februar 2009 10 erlassen wurde ist
für mich nach wie vor rechtswidrig ich
bin der auffassung vertrete ich auch
ganz klar auch wenn der minister meint
ich würde da eine starke minder meinung
vertreten genau in diesem fall und man
genau das ließ was die bafin vom eigenen
handeln meint hätte hier letztlich eine
genehmigung seitens des
finanzministeriums erfolgen müssen das
wird sicherlich noch viele viele
rechtsgelehrte beschäftigen vielleicht
aber auch gerichte an dieser stelle
wir haben wieder einmal einen minister
erlebt er mit fast allem und nichts zu
tun hatte der berühmt bekannte teflon
olaf scholz ist hier wieder zum ausdruck
gekommen und ich denke dass er
nachträglich vom leerverkaufsverbot
erfuhr eine einmaligkeit im
bundesfinanzministerium eine
einmaligkeit bei der deutschen
finanzaufsicht und davon will er nicht
informiert werden die wesentlichen
höchsten beamten des bmf nämlich dem
beamten rolle wimmer und franke haben
sich intensiv auch mit dem startkurs
ausgetauscht und gleichzeitig ist eine
mail an die büroleitung von herrn scholz
gegangen und er will uns erzählen hätte
am montag erst davon erfahren entweder
funktioniert in diesem ministerium nicht
der gerade weg zum minister oder es wird
hier etwas grob hilfe schwiegen
olaf scholz hat als manager hat als
entscheider hat als politischer
verantwortungsträger durch wirecard
schon einige schrammen abbekommen wie
viele es noch werden wie viele dazu
kommen das wird sich erst noch zeigen
er hat sich heute vor allem darum bemüht
wirecard ganz weit von ihm persönlich
weg zu behalten
er hat sich
olaf scholz hat sich heute bemüht den
fall wirecard ganz weit von sich weg zu
halten
er hat dafür die bafin kritisiert er hat
sich distanziert von der finanzaufsicht
aber was ihm nicht gelungen ist es zu
sagen und zu erklären warum denn dann
wenn die finanzaufsicht fehler begangen
hat das ministerium alles richtig
gemacht hat
und genau da liegt die unstimmigkeit
liegt die inkonsequenz auch in seiner
heutigen aussage es ist deutlich
geworden dass die finanzaufsicht sehr
wohl eine ganze menge instrumente hatte
die sie nicht nutzen konnte sie hatte
hinweise auf straftaten durch ein
marschalek aber die wurden eben nicht an
die staatsanwaltschaft weitergegeben
sie hatte die möglichkeit über eine
prüfung an die der wirecard bank auch
die muttergesellschaft mit zu prüfen sie
hat das sogar überlegt erwogen aber eben
einfach am ende nicht gemacht sie hatte
die möglichkeit neben der kontrolle der
bilanzen durch die dpr auch selber in
eigener hand in eigener regie die
kapitalmarktkommunikation von wirecard
man kann auch sagen die öffentlichen
lügen von wirecard dies über jahre
hinweg gab zu untersuchen
dieses instrument wurde nicht ausgewählt
ausschnitte aus den reaktionen der ob
leute auf die heutige
untersuchungsausschuss sitzung mit olaf
scholz dem bundesfinanzminister diese
reaktionen dauern noch an
deswegen muss ich eben dieser stelle
eine pointe an dieser stelle
vorwegnehmen es gab heftige kritik am
finanzminister er habe nicht alle mails
die relevanz hatten im zusammenhang mit
dem wettskandal hier vorgelegt die habe
man in anderen unterlagen in anderen
akten gefunden das scheint sich als ein
trugschluss entpuppt zu haben denn der
die spd ob leute mitglieder des
untersuchungsausschusses mittlerweile
vorgelegt dass diese mails durchaus in
den akten auch des bundesministeriums
der finanzen vorhanden waren
offenbar haben insbesondere
unionsabgeordnete diese seiten diese
mails nicht gesehen so viel für den
moment morgen kommt die bundeskanzlerin
in diesem untersuchungsausschuss und
dann sind die befragungen auch
abgeschlossen bundeskanzlerin wird
gefragt werden dazu warum sie für
wirecard geworben hat auch in china
während einer reise wo es um solche
wirtschaftlichen fragen ging der wird
sich noch mal aufregend wahrscheinlich
für viele und einen großen auftritt noch
mal geben und dann sieht die anhörung
dieses untersuchungsausschusses auch
abgeschlossen und wir werden ganz sicher
wieder darüber berichten
berlin